what's up guys i'm lauren gray here with
buzzfeed and today i'm going to be
sliding into
my own dms
so i'm going to go into my requested
inbox right now
on instagram and see what kind of
messages are inside
i get a lot of dms like this uh where
people i think are having like a
one-sided conversation
this one says oops hey lauren
hehe hey baby you okay
lauren i love you i'm sorry ugh i
forgive you
for whatever it is that you're
apologizing for okay this one's really
nice
uh this one says hi lauren i'm one of
your biggest fans and i wanted to meet
you since you started musically in 2015
i make edits for you on my page i'm 14
and i love you so much i hope you stay
safe and have an amazing day i know you
might not see this
but i really appreciate all the nice
things you've done and how amazing you
are with your fans if you see this
you mean the world to me so that's just
a nice one and i get a lot of those
those are my favorite kind of dm so
thank you the next one
says are you a camera by chance and
there's no follow-up to that but i'm
really
really curious as to what the follow-up
could have
and would have been because i'm not a
camera this one says this was the
perfect story for me to reply on but
honestly it left me speechless
and then he dm'd again a few hours later
and said i was thinking about the odds
of you answering
then i realized if i message you at
least once a day they go up by a lot
if anyone sees this they'll think i'm
crazy but you're just like wow
and then in the next message
the next day so he had this whole thing
where he was going to message me every
day
and then the day after that he said all
right i gave up
can't make a fool of myself for you
we'll meet someday he gave up pretty
quickly
but i respect it and i respect the
hustle the next one's pretty
straightforward
can you literally marry me and then
replies again
in a couple hours and says please marry
me so he's a bit more polite
the next time but i'm not sure i'm
looking for that kind of commitment
right now
i do get a few marriage proposals
um although i did get proposed to once
when i was on tour in person and that
was
kind of awkward but we made it through
we're not married i'm not married
just putting that out there the next dm
is one of my favorites
um because all he said was chocolate
queen
and that i am not i'm not sure what
context he meant that in
but i he followed it up with three kissy
faces so i it was a pause it was meant
to be a positive
sometimes people will send me hate
messages
to my dms which i actually think is
quite nice because they're keeping it
between us
and not you know publicly like
commenting um so this one just says hate
you lauren
and i really appreciate it it's to the
point and
you know she didn't do a public leash
she made it private
and she just wanted to let me know how
she feels i respect it this one says
you look like kylie jenner which
i don't see the resemblance at all
actually but
i guess it's a compliment so i guess i
will say thank you
the next one just says you are doing
well honey
i appreciate that sometimes you just
need a little motivation
this person said you have good natural
lashes
with mascara so they were letting me
know that my natural lashes are good
but they need a little bit of help so
thank you
this one i like because they've thrown
in some like
you know when you put or numbers instead
of letters they've done that to like
make the
the message more interesting there's my
queen in her majestic
verse scene i could stare at those all
day
in every light array i feel like that
was a very heavy
like really deep message also could have
been pulled from like pinterest
i like this one because i've i got a
nickname that i've never heard before
hey princess yoda i'm not sure what
that's supposed to mean
i saw that everyone is trying to reach
your attention but i didn't see that
someone asked you how are you
how was your day how's quarantine going
what do you do through these
days i love you so much and i hope you
could answer have a great day and stay
safe
yeah princess yoda that's me i guess and
this person
says i look like allison from the movie
pretty little liars
but i'm pretty sure it's a show i've
never really seen it
but i don't know if there's a
resemblance i don't know maybe it's just
a lot of people just compare me to
people who have blonde hair i'll take it
as a compliment
thank you guys so much for watching and
coming into my instagram dms with me
i have a new single out right now called
cake so check it out if you want
and thanks for having me buzzfeed
you